I am not Shakespeare,
so I cannot come up with a
Facebook message that will
express how powerful of an
impact you and echo have had on my life.
My father died when I was 10 and I spent
the next 12 years wasting my physical
and mental gifts.
You've taught me many of the lessons that
I like to believe my father would have
taught me if he were alive.
Here's a brief list of my achievements
over the past two years that you deserve
at least partial credit too.
Here we go. Lost 90 pounds.
Net weight,
300 from 300 pounds down to two 10.
Yeah, that's a big difference. Yeah.
People weigh 90 pounds. By the way.
You also hold person. Yeah. Dead lift.
Max went from two 25 to four 55.
Legit bench.
Went from one 85 to three 15
extra legit, uh, started
training. Jujitsu. Boom.
Boom. Yeah. And boxing with friends.
Even though there's nowhere to
train where I currently live,
except for the yoga room at La Fitness.
You can make it happen in
the yoga room at La Fitness.
Let's get it all in the yoga room
and elevators that talking about
Glenn. I'm like online heart. I think they
did it. I think you'll like they fought.
Anyway. That's a whole
nother thing. Anyway,
we spent two years working at an awful
job where I lead from the middle and
improve the output of the entire facility
while adding to my own skillset to the
point where I was able to
get a job, get a job. I love.
That's awesome.
That's awesome to be bragging about the
fact that you had an awful job that you
just got after it and, and look what
happened. Guess what the results are.
You get the job that you wanted.
Shelby love. Yup. Started at
the new job last Wednesday,
so that just happened.
Boom.
Legit NC started taking
class for the next job.
I want on a Coursera must be
some kind of an internet thing.
Um, I'm halfway through the data science
certification program. Yeah. Settings.
I'm currently 26 and I fully intend to
get after it until the day I die of past
your lessons onto my younger brother
who has lost 50 pounds and swings the
Kettlebell. I got him everyday. Dang.
When I lacked the motivation
to do what needs to be done,
your words ring the loud in
my ears. Discipline equals
freedom. Thank you so much.
Okay, so the, my quit. The
question is, um, you may not,
the reason I included this
preamble of kind of what he's been,
you're going to hear, but as I thought
about how to answer this question, I,
it's good to know what the background
is and what successes he's had.
That's where we kind of threw that in
there cause it's, and, and it's awesome.
It's awesome to hear about a trooper
just getting after it. Dang numbers too.
That's the thing. Yeah. That's the
good thing about like, you know,
somebody you can say, Hey, I'm
getting after it nowadays. Good, good.
But if I'm dead lifting four 55,
this guy's like kind of finding after it,
here's how, here's how my my
results. Awesome. Um, Kay Jocko,
you may not have this issue.
How do you avoid feeling discouraged when
you realize how much of your life you
wasted when you're not getting after it?
Do you ever worry
that you won't achieve your full
potential because you wasted time?
Well, first of all, like I
said, first and foremost,
congratulations second.
That's just legit.
And to have made that much progress,
you're obviously on the path and getting
after it and what you've accomplished
is awesome.
Some people never make that transition,
so stay on and keep crushing it.
Now,
as far as discouragement goes from
not having gotten on the path earlier,
m w do I feel that way? Would I
feel that way? Negative. Don't know.
Okay. You were a little late getting
in the game, but I'll tell you what,
26 years old, is that what we're
talking about? 26 yeah. At 26 years old.
You're young and you're young and
a, but I'll tell you what, even if,
even if you are 40 or 50
or 60 or 70 doesn't matter.
You're in the game now and that's,
that's what counts.
And all those quote unquote wasted
years, they, they weren't wasted, right?
They're not wasted because you learned.
And specifically what did he learn about?
Learned about what it's
like to be out of shape,
learned about what it's
like to be overweight,
learn about what it's like to be weak.
And the knowledge that you learned about
those things is fuel to make sure that
it never happens again.
Cause you know,
you know what is out there and
do you know how bad it can get.
And in this is the other reason
why it's beneficial that you,
you have a pass that wasn't perfect is
now you can teach other people how to do
it very clearly.
You know,
you can inspire other people to
do a look at what you did. Do you,
what'd you do to your brother? You know?
Right. It's another good example that,
so back in the day before
anybody knew what Jujitsu was,
dairy,
uh,
I am the worst person to introduce Jujitsu
to people because when they see me,
cause I'm 225 pounds and um,
you know,
a big guy and they think, of course this
guy can choke me. Of course, you know,
they, they don't expect anything else.
So when I choked them, they're like,
well yeah,
you are really strong.
So the best people to introduce Jujitsu
to people is like Jeff Glover. Yeah.
Right? Who's 150 pounds, the skinny guy.
And he comes out and shows
you a big strong guy 27
times in a row. They say, oh,
maybe this stuff works well. It's the
same thing here. People look at me, they
gold jock jock who just hardcore,
no, not just me looking at you.
You're the one that did it.
You went through a much bigger transition
than I've ever gone through in my life.
Yeah.
So I say you embrace what you
learned from the weekdays.
Let them,
let them make you even stronger
and you use your own personal
transformation that you've made in life.
Use that to help other people
transform and get on the path as well.
That's where I'm at.
So good.
And there's a lot to be said too for
that. Like, like how he was talking,
this is what I think you mean is
how his brother lost 50 pounds.
Right? So, and that's like a lot,
like a lot of times I feel like when
people will do good stuff for themselves
and make these big changes,
other people who see there's kind of,
there's two P, I'm sure there's one, two,
but there's two kinds of people were,
some will be like,
and they'll just hate and there'll be
just jealous and they'll, you know,
whatever. But the legit people
like in your life are around,
you are going to be like,
Hey, what'd you do? You know?
Even if like even if it's not losing,
even if it's like you're making like
millions of dollars now, they're like, oh,
like what are you doing? You know,
you just sorta changed real quick.
Like you're now, you're making millions
out. What'd you do? I want to do,
I want to get on that stuff. Whatever
you're doing. And the workout thing,
that's a big one. So if like,
like a lot of times I girls,
they'll lose all this weight and now
they're like super chat there, you know,
as attractive as they always want it to
be kind of thing. All the other girls,
what did you do? Oh my gosh.
What'd you do? What'd you do?
And they want to do it too.
It's like,
it's almost like almost like you
can prove to other walk can be done.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly. It's
good shit. Stay on that path, man.
That's awesome.